Recall that our original goal was
not just to evaluate a polynomial at
the roots of unity but rather to
multiply two polynomials together or
even more generally to convolve
two sequences of numbers together.
The faster way to transform would seem
only to get us a little past halfway.
So let's go back and
look at our road map to see where we are
in multiplying two polynomials together.
Let's take a step back and
see where we are in trying to find
a faster way to multiply polynomials.
We have an N logN way to
evaluate the polynomials,
we can then multiply them in the value
representation easily in N time,
but the interpolation
step remains a problem.
Remember that this runtime
involved inverting or
applying Gaussian elimination
to a Vandermonde matrix.
Or to get the square here, we could
have used Lagrange interpolation.